hello hey my friend I got that kid I was  talking to you about him I'm gonna put  him on the phone let you talk to him  okay oh yes  hi you're Frank this is Jimmy Hoffa glad  to meet you  glad to meet you too even if it's over  the phone our friend speaker I hear you  thank you  only three people in the world that one  of these  at home in one of them is Irish I heard  you paint houses yes I do so where are  you going  go to work well you know there's a  situation going on now Frank big  business and the government they're  trying to pull us down you might be  demonstrating the failure to show  appreciation I know things they don't  know I know  you can't miss the big picture sooner or  later  everybody could hear as a date he's  gonna go  you want to be a part of this fight  would you like to be a part of this  history yes I would  whatever you need me to do I'm available  he likes a tough dog  you